[Applause]
how are you hi
oh my goodness i'm so excited to be
speaking with you
it's an honor to be in the whole scream
franchise with you
whoa okay wait one thank you two
i know i was freaking out because the
the scream cast and directors we have
this group chat and we all still talk to
each other
so i told them i was like guys i'm
talking with drew should i just spoil
the whole film
one of the directors matt told me oh
yeah i could send you the whole cut
right now she could put it on your show
no you haven't yeah like how excited i
am to be speaking with you
how much we praise your film i remember
on halloween even
we um went on our set we set up a
projector and we got popcorn and watched
the original like i cannot tell you
how many times i have seen your opening
scene
i am so honored to be a part of this
franchise with you
and by the way i only made it this far
in the book last night but i just
i can't tell you it's the whole thing is
circled
and annotated page after page after page
it's so beautiful um
what inspired you to write this book
just growing up in this day and age
where social media can be so
harmful and so toxic to young people's
mental health or even or even older
people i think it's
it's really important to know that um
people that you see on the screen or
or people that you know you may support
go through the same things that you do
and we all kind of struggle with
self-esteem or self-love and
it's a tough journey to get there and i
think that with this book i really just
wanted to reach out to people who
may also be struggling or people who
just wanted to get to know myself
a little bit better and that's why
there's so many intimate stories or
embarrassing stories or
mistakes that i've made that people may
or may not learn from
you have the wisdom of someone who's
lived an entire life cycle
and you know where do you think you
learned
for example like when you know
you love someone maybe don't keep the
mementos can you speak to that
i love that i know for me personally i
live in the past a lot
and i think that sometimes that kind of
stops or
halts my growth as a person because i'm
so stuck at what happened in the past or
things that i'm embarrassed of or
mistakes that i've made that
i don't appreciate the present time that
i'm in
or i'm i am so stuck on that that i just
can't
move forward i mean mementos tend to be
memories of the good times and never the
bad times
so if you're only holding on to these
amazing pieces or
pieces that made you smile or when you
think about this person or friend or
whoever it may be i think it um is just
kind of holding you back in a sense and
i know for me i'm trying to
live a bit of a a more minimalist
lifestyle so i try to keep things as
plain as simple as i possibly can be
especially with how crowd in my brain
can be sometimes
and again those mementos they just kind
of crowd your thoughts and um kind of
fog your memory in a sense i think you
also talk about the difference between
love and infatuation will you speak to
that
yeah um again social media it's so easy
for people to
portray this perfect clean beautiful
lifestyle that i i really think that
social media
people just post and appear how how they
want to be rather than they truly are
people who haven't experienced that
before this infatuation this crush that
they start to
develop it could feel like true love and
when they meet that person or start to
interact that
interact with that person and realize
that they're not as perfect as
they their mind had made them out to be
i think you could be disappointed and
it's unfair to that other person to be
disappointed
because of the expectations that you
created in your own head
um i just i i don't think that we should
take social media so seriously and so
deeply and
base people's or create these ideas
about somebody
who um truly is just trying to appear
cool
or you know be well liked or popular
whatever it may be whatever they're
trying to achieve on
instagram you have so much to offer
you are such a gift jenna ortega
everybody it's all love
reflections for your heart and soul is
available
right now jenna ortega it is such a
pleasure to get to know you
and please i would love to see you again
thank you it's an honor
[Music]